The last thing that I want to quickly
discuss ,are some functions that usually exist in query
languages like SQL. Such as ,group bys and
aggregate functions. So let's say that I wanted to
create some transformed version of my data. For
example, what are the total number of enrollments per
district? . I could write something like this. Select
district,. Sum (aadhaar - generated) from aadhaar - data,
group by district. Let's talk about this
a little bit more. What's happening exactly?
. Sum is what we call an aggregate function. An aggregate function takes some
set of values, usually numbers and performs
a mathematical operation on them. We've used
sum ,but other aggregate functions include count.
Min, mean, max. You get the idea.
Operations that one could perform on a collection
of numbers. But wait. Every single row is
only one number. So how do we get
to collections of numbers? What we basically say here
is take each distinct district. And then for
all of the different values of aadhaar_generated corresponding
to a row ,for that district. Sum them
up. So, we start with our aadhaar data table.
Take each district ,and sum up the count aadhaar
generated. Now in order for our results to make
sense, we are only going to want one row
in our output for each district. So we throw in
this group by clause on the end, which essentially
says. Let's only have one row per district in
our results. There can be numerous clauses in a
group buy. So we could also say this, select district,
subdistrict, sum aadhaar generated, from aadhaar data, group
by district, subdistrict. Note that whatever columns we
select, that we don't aggregate, we need to
group by. In this case, district and sub-district. We
could also put a where clause here, so
in order to sum up aadhaar generated for people
over 60 in each district, I can just add a where clause in after the table name,
as we discussed earlier. If we were to run this query. Giving us select
district, sub-district, sum aadhaar generated, from aadhaar data,
where age greater than 60, group by district, sub-district. If we
were to run this query, we would have
a row for every combination of district and
subdistrict. And we would also have for each
row, account of how many aadhaar were generated ,for
people over the age of 60.